Một tháng 11, hãy quần đi Suran đáng nâng đổi tổ cú trở của Tế Global Sú mốt
Gồn khoảng 50 tổ chở hơn 5 trăm tình huyện viên từ 11,000 cú gia
Măng thú phần và thung mêng tới rải gà ra
Suran cáu buộc ha mắt đứng sau hỏa động này
Đồng thời bác sử mù súng tạo và đưa hành khách về cảnh của nước này
Bộ hỏi sạo Suran khẩn định quá trình diễn xả an toàn
Tuy nhiên, đồng thấy này lập tất là bương lên là nắm sống phản đổi từ cú tế
Dới chú bù đời nhé trở biệt có bác công dân nước này bị bác sử ước
Chúng khi ít alí pháp tế bàn nhà và thủ nghĩ kì đều yêu cầu Suran bảo đảm ảnh và quyền được bảo hủ lạnh sự
Môi trường của phòng ít alí gư Joe Grossetto chỉ chính mạnh mẽ và cho biết đã cửa hải quần đến hủ trở
Từ Mỹ là tình, tổng thống của Lâm Bia Costa Gó Pê Chó không chỉ chục xuất phai bộ ngoại sạo Suran
Mà còn trấm rất hiệp định thương mại tự dòng gió hành nước
Mà lấy tiè sân nhận có táng công dân bị bác sử và cũng lên nạn gây các thành động này
Ở các đổ tăng công, chúng cú kêu gọi Suran chấm rất ngay hoàn đậm quân sự tại khá ra
Dân kế hoạch nhằm và thành phố gà ra và không vũ kì hoá hiện trận nhé đạo
Bác kì đồng thời hủy thuộc cậm đồng của tế thuộc đầy giải pháp hành nhé nước
Hoa đầy là còn đường dưới nhất trong hoa bình lúc dài ở Palestine